- Hier ist der Heizungskeller und …
ja, einmal bitte warten.
- Natürlich. Wir werden jetzt
hier was auslegen
und uns danach um die
Heizung kümmern.
- Okay, danke.
- Dann werden wir uns
mal um die Heizung kümmern.
Was müssen wir als
Erstes machen?
- Als Erstes mal den Brenner aufmachen.
- Ausschalten. Wir müssen
den Brenner ausschalten.
So, die Heizung ist aus.
Und nun werden wir unten
mal sauber machen,
uns mal angucken, wie der
Brennerraum aussieht.
Du holst jetzt bitte mal den Staubsauger.
Und dann werden wir mal den
Brennerraum aussaugen.
Kannst du den Sauger bitte wegräumen?
- Ja.
Was wird als Nächstes gemacht?
- Als Nächstes werden wir
den Aschebehälter ausleeren.
Andreas, gehst du bitte mal
den Messkoffer vom Auto holen?
- Ja klar, mach ich.
- Gibst du mir bitte das Messgerät?
- Was gibt es denn für eine
Obergrenze für den CO-Wert?
- Also beim CO-Wert ist es so, dass der
immer möglichst tief sein sollte.
In der Regel liegt der so bei 15.
Aber wenn der dann höher
schießen sollte auf bis über 500,
dann wird die Anlage
sofort stillgelegt,
weil das schädliche CO dann in zu hoher
Konzentration in die Luft kommt.
- Okay.
- Aber das hier, das passt so weit alles.
- So, war alles in Ordnung?
- Genau, wir haben Ihre Heizung gewartet.
Mit der Heizung ist alles in Ordnung.
Ich hab hier unseren Zettel fertig gemacht:
Wir haben die Anlage gewartet,
wir haben auch die Abgase
gemessen – das passt alles.
Da müssen Sie sich keine Sorgen
machen. Wir waren so lange hier.
Und da bekomme ich bitte von
Ihnen dort eine Unterschrift.
- Gerne.
- Super, ich danke Ihnen. Ich wünsche
Ihnen noch einen schönen Tag
und wir verabschieden uns.
- Einen schönen Tag noch, tschüss.
- Schönen Tag noch!